À mes amis d'agence orale,
aujourd'hui, c'est 1 honneur pour moi,
c'est 1 moment très important pour le combat des
des rureaux, pour ce monde désoublié,
pour ces gens qui n'ont jamais 1 mot à dire
à Bruxelles comme en France souvent,
j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer que
mon ami Jean lazzal
nous a rejoint.
Jean, il fallait qu'on le fasse ensemble.
Ces 2 grandes gueules du monde rural
vont enfin porter la voie des oubliés.
La campagne, on le voit bien,
pleure, elle est abandonnée,
elle se voit tomber sous les yeux.
Et j'ai trouvé ce rock.
Je savais qu'il était costaud,
mais depuis que je l'ai croisé,
je me suis dit-il n'y a pas de doute, c'est lui !
Quel bonheur de te retrouver ! Alors ensemble,
ensemble, maintenant,
nous allons construire cette victoire.
Le monde rural va l'emporter,
le monde rural va enfin être écouté et entendu.
Merci aux résistants de m'avoir permis.
Regardez, oh ! Pour notre rêve.